right sorry that I'm late huh
there we go okay so I suppose I
explained it's gotta be at a tilted
angle folks I'm sorry that's just gonna
be what it is except that's gonna bug me
apologies to all I really hate this
thing sometimes screw it okay so to
explain the name on the live stream next
week there will not be a live stream
because I will be on vacation
all week which actually means I'm
working flat out the rest of this week
to get everything I need done part of
the reason why I'm slightly late is I
lost track of time while working on the
editing the bisexual representation
video which is going up on Friday then
after I do that I have to work on
Sunday's video Wednesday next week is
already set but I got a lot of work to
do on Mondays can't remember what I have
set for Friday next week
I think shot it time there's not enough
of it hi everybody I made it back from
California a couple days ago well I'm
glad you made it home alright
ah Oh welcome back meg it's nice to have
you here hair look straight hair looks
like a hot mess
like I mean after this is done I need to
I need a shower
Irish Coffee water Dead's that is not uh
you know six ice cubes in there you know
just saying I mean I know hi scoff he is
a thing but ah your hair is always so
pretty I'll just I'll just accept the
compliment and move on from there I
recently started watching Gotham after
my brother binge watch all five season
I am almost done season two I really
enjoy the crime-drama aspect in the
gritty realism I know the show will
change a little bit if you're hooking
initially - Gotham is the gritty realism
I'm not gonna say you won't enjoy what's
coming after it depends on your taste
but that that's garnish yeah as time
goes on how's your week been
ah it's a week that's so that oh god
that that cats trailer was the glorious
train wreck I anticipated it to be I
cannot wait for it that trailer holy
crap okay first of all I'm one of those
people who just doesn't like cats I
don't mean the animal I mean the show I
just got someone's gonna mmm take that
as a clip out of context but anyways I
don't like the show cats I never have I
don't particularly even like the songs I
really don't like it like as a visual
person like I I understand what is good
about it on stage but like seeing that
trailer for that film it added a whole
uncanny valley aspect to it because it's
all being done CGI and I'm like this is
even more unsettling than it already was
which I didn't think was possible Oh
John never would have shown actual cats
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna like I look
I did I got I ranted out Lion King I
don't need to beat up Jon Favreau
specifically I've no doubt that he was
working on very clear directives on what
Disney wanted this movie to be I hope
you have a wonderful time in Holland on
holiday thank you very much nightmare
cast nightmare fuel for the next
generation yikes yeah and actually you
know it's worth saying about Favreau
real quick except for when he goes
independent which he has done every now
and then when he does studio work he's
he's a bit of a gun for hire he
he delivers what a studio has asked him
to deliver I think he's a good director
I wouldn't call him a visionary he's not
someone who he's one of those directors
who doesn't elevate material he's gonna
take the the script and you know the
directors from the studio and deliver
that at a high level but he's not gonna
metamorphose it into something I've row
in a ball park with like Ron Howard on
that same level and this is not to decry
either of them that you can like the
whole idea of being a director for hire
is you're often maligned but like you
can do that it'd be very good at your
craft that's not a knock where are you
going implication that it's a it's a
family vacation so that is personal I
try I'm fairly protective about you know
family details us when it comes to my
kids so you'll forgive me not answering
that way I see it 2d animation gives
artists more creative freedom that you
can't pull off a CGI I see I used to
believe that I'm not sure that's true
anymore because we've hit a point where
there isn't a standardized look for CGI
anymore I felt like there was for a
while but I do feel like at this point
like you look at something from saying
like I don't love these films but you
look at the Hotel Transylvania movies
genndy tartakovsky so I don't think CGI
is inherently restricting to the
artistic possibilities I think more
often than not they feel like if they
achieve a certain level of realism that
they don't have to be artistic with it I
think there's a trap there but I don't
think it's actually inherent to CGI
animation as a medium
personally I don't understand why cats
had to be CGI the show had some of the
best costume onstage for one very simple
reason they wanted really big name
actors and really big name actors don't
want to sit through eight hours of
makeup they never would have gotten Judi
Dench they never would have gotten Ian
McKellen they probably wouldn't have
gotten a dress elbow they wouldn't have
gotten Taylor Swift and whether or not
you think these are good gets you know
the the number of actor of like big-name
actors willing to sit in a makeup chair
for hours pretty small but put a bunch
of dots on their face having just prance
around a green screen set shirt they'll
do that I google the Harley Quinn
trailers see what comes up uh yep the
the Harley Quinn trailer it could be fun
III forget the format I can't remember
if it's gonna be like short like
15-minute episodes or something um I
don't know if I'm misremembering that if
that is what it is like I'm more
interested in it then than if they're
trying to like build big narratives out
of it poor Zoe Saldana has done some
time in the makeup chair between avatar
and guardians of the galaxy yeah she's
been on both sides of that that equation
what's up
stuff I guess
castus ISM for a movie audience the
thing is I could never figure out what
theater audience cats was for either but
then again like maybe I'm just a weirdo
there oh my god Elva all CGI hub then in
that suit cat bond look I won't lie even
with the uncanny valley thing Alba
looked kinda yeah hmm did you catch any
of the Big Finish live stream this last
weekend I popped on to it briefly I
think it was doing spare parts when I
popped on there I just I was too busy
with other stuff but yeah I did I did
catch a little of it have you likes how
did you like series 5 a black mirror as
a whole compared to the others see
that's a weird question for me because
I've never really judged black mirror on
a series by series basis because every
episode is so self-contained I take them
completely as their own thing I
I've never really liked I and even in my
head it's not like I don't remember what
episodes were one series I actually do
remember but like I still don't I don't
know my brain won't categorize them that
that way I guess thoughts on the recent
double-oh-seven news oh give me the the
fact that that designation not the
character of James James Bond but that
double oh um designation is gonna be
going to a black woman like fine I mean
like it it's one of those things where I
really hate clickbait headline titles
for videos or articles because the the
clickbait headline is James Bond will be
a black woman which and this is not
what's going on and the other thing is I
like I haven't been following this super
close because like the production on the
James Bond movies have been kind of a
mess lately this one particularly so I
got a headache trying to keep up with it
so I don't know if it's been confirmed
or not but I see people also acting like
going forward all future
your films are gonna have this woman in
the role I don't think that's been
confirmed I think it's just this film
the double low ranked the
double-oh-seven
designation goes to this woman but James
Bond is also still there err and in my
mind like we'll see what how it turns
out a and then B what they do with it in
the future but like that is a framing
that's totally fine like you realize
double-oh-seven is not his name like
that's the sis's v designation and if he
dies or retires somebody else is going
to get it that's a perfectly viable
narrative somebody else taking on that
designation but he's still around in
some fashion now I'm like I'm curious to
see how that ends up being I'm paranoid
because I I really hate it Spectre I
hated it what is your opinion of Timothy
Dalton his bond moment of honesty I
haven't seen all of either of his Bond
films I mean I've never not liked
Timothy Dalton in anything I've seen him
in so I'll probably still like him but
like I haven't seen those movies I could
never get into James Bond he's just too
much of a sexist ass for me to get into
him I mean I think it just has to what
has a lot to do with sort of where you
are where you first start experiencing
him hi because I came into James Bond
with golden eyes so that came out what
95 I would have been 13 like however I
identify now at 13 you know even with a
little bit of gender early gender
fluctuations 30 I was very much a boy I
was a 30 year old boy
so yeah James Bond had an appeal to me
there a dream doctor and companion
pairing that never happened um I would
honestly I'd really like to see a swift
Kapali
I read the books and to be honest he was
kind of a sexist ass in the books well
of course he was I mean that's that's
the thing like with something like James
Bond first of all you do have to I mean
as the franchise has continued you can
make an argument that they should be
evolving with the times but certainly
for when it was written and what it was
meant to be there is definitely a degree
of you know thing of its time but also
with a character like that and what he
was meant to embody because James Bond
as a character represented this weird
ideal of British of like British
influence and colonialization to a
certain certain degree filtered through
this lens of espionage as he John
surround the world dropping into these
countries to deal with the bad people
and fix the problems that already exist
in these nations it was very much a
national identity fantasy filtered
through this man and it was a masculine
national identity fantasy so with a
control like that how he treats women at
the very least that his initial
inception that's a feature not a bug you
know whatever your own feelings about it
might be how many illegitimate children
do you think bond has here's something I
wish bond would do or honestly so many
films in general just take a second and
have him grab a condom like seriously
takes it takes one shot two seconds I
really wish that we just like would
normalize his safe sex practices in
these things because it's like there's
no reason not to this is like oh it
breaks up for them of like okay it
doesn't break up the moment in real life
all that much anyways but and I felt
like just you're not gonna show the full
safety in any way just show a hand going
for a drawer or a pocket whoever kind of
boom I remember this this super bothered
me um when I watched uh orphan black
because I think it's actually the very
first episode
how do we even explain orphan black okay
I didn't for the purposes of what I'm
about to talk about all you need to know
is there's a whole bunch of women who
look exactly the same they're clones but
so one of them goes into this home that
another one was in and she she she's
broken in but she covers herself by
pretending to be this other woman who
looks just like her coming out of the
shower and this guy has come in there
who's obviously the lover and pretending
to be this other woman she then has sex
with him now what really bothered me
about that scene cuz I get that she's
like trying to not give away that she's
not who he thinks she is but what super
bothered me about that scene is she
starts the scene naked so she has no
pockets and he just strips down and they
go at it right there on the counter and
I mean I think it was psyche i Channel
but like it's edit in such a way that
there is very clearly no time or pause
made to get a condom I'm like you don't
know this guy
what are you doing that really ticked me
off because it was played off as you
know fun or sexy I'm like chick no come
on
like I'd like to see it in general just
become normalized getting a condom but
to see a scene like that where there's
explicitly no freakin way
there could have been one that taped me
off I don't hold that against bonds so
much again unless we're talking like
last decade or so but or maybe from the
90s on but you know prior to that I'm
like is it just is what it is huh dad
mode engaged
oh why don't I just drop in on safe sex
chat that apparently like there's a
couple things that I would love to see
normalized in terms of depictions of
sexual scenes between characters I would
love to see safe sex normalized and I
would love to see consent normalized
because again much like safe sex
we get on this topic I don't know I'm
running with it much like with safe sex
there's this whole notion that oh you
can't get explicit consent because it
kills the moment like no if you if you
properly trust your partner and they and
like you have a level of communication
at all and sometimes you can establish
that quickly you then you can make
getting consent sexy consent is sexy and
mandatory dialects of the same sex yes
you're more engaging than my sex head
teacher ah I was really lucky when I was
in high school I didn't have to take
health class because I was I had the
ability to test out of it I was given a
test like here like you need to prove it
you know these things about sexuality
and Anatomy and birth control etc I'm
like and I took the test and I knew the
stuff I'd have to take the class yeah
and stop being afraid of nipples holy
cow yes like what the day uh and I'm
also boy this hmm I was debating whether
or not I would screw it I'll just say
like the thing is I don't because I have
chest development a bit now since I went
on the testosterone blockers I don't
know if like Facebook or Instagram would
consider my nipples to be offensive I
mean I'm like if I'm in full femme
presenting like full makeup that's like
okay but like if I'm not and like
there's distinct curvature there at this
point would I be censored I don't know I
don't really want to test it but I like
I've wondered
oh man oh man there's so many comments
be held for review just cuz we're
talking about sex go god this thing's
gonna get to monetize I'm accepting that
already I can't talk about it's
confidential anyway how's your sex life
[Laughter]
trans nipples are forbidden sadly well
that's see the thing it like I know that
like if I identified it as a trans woman
ya know who they would be but like I'm
in that weird no gray area so I don't
know
excuse me pétain versus absorbed a lot
for the series 12 finale along I'm okay
I'm gonna move that say because every
time I was like nudging this the whole
camera was shaking um if your nipples
aren't crear is go see a doctor did you
have time to catch the Picard trailer I
did like okay I had the whole project
just strikes me is so weird I don't
really know what to think of it well
thank you mag much appreciated so safe
sex isn't normalized in all schools in
the US let alone in media cuz god forbid
we give women the idea that sex is fun
and safe well oh god yeah we start
because like I'm very fortunate that
like I had the ability to test out of
sex ed but the the goal of the sex ed at
my high school was to actually be
informative about this stuff and I test
it out not because I got a religious
exemption I test it out cuz I already
knew what they were gonna teach me which
was actually pretty thorough the stuff
on that test that I had to pass Star
Trek Star Trek set after nemesis is a
blessing but I'm worried what they'll do
with it I'd say that's fair I it is nice
to finally have the timeline move
forward like for crying out loud
like especially and I still haven't
watched Discovery but especially if
they're gonna design Discovery the way
they do and claim its pre original
seriously no none of this lines up
visually technologically so like just
move the thing forward
I hate that some schools still only
teach abstinence oh yeah because because
horniness will beat out any teachings
they do in school yeah the the apps
the abstinence only thing is like that's
like we're in the weeds on this at this
point the abstinence only thing is just
so bizarre to me
especially just like because the
internet exists like at all so I don't
know what you think you're protecting
kids from but they're gonna find
everything that you are trying to keep
them from but at the same time if
they're gonna find out about this stuff
anyway don't you want them to be told by
someone who knows what the hell they're
talking about
instead of getting no information and
being able to look up porn and using
that is a substitute for information
good god and that like I get it because
as a parent like I'm not looking forward
to these conversations with my daughter
but like it's part of the gig or it
should be I think sex ed it should be
taught by adult movie stars
[Music]
maybe thoughts on the rumor of the
possibility of series 12 doing a story
based on Frankenstein despite the fact
Big Finish already did that story okay
um I I have Cybermen will remove sex I
have no specific thoughts on that
journal concept but what I will say is I
have absolutely no issue with the show
redoing stories that were done in Big
Finish they've done it already
Dalek was bit was based to look directly
off a big finished story world enough in
time took a lot of inspiration from
spare parts and they're great and like I
know so I know people who actually
listen to Big Finish get annoyed was
like what you why do your own thing and
you're you're making it so you know
people won't discover this if I might
look it's good material and way more
people watch the show than listen to the
audios I don't want them to start just
doing nothing but adapting audios but
like once a series once in a blue moon
which is basically what it is yeah I
consider it fair game I recently
listened to Jubilee now I want to listen
to Holy Terror Holy Terror is still my
favorite and there's really good stuff
on Big Finish I love the Holy Terror
though like it hits it hits all my
buttons and the best way the worst is
how schools and society will preach
abstinence but then crap on people who
are asexual and think their way of not
liking sex being repulsed well yeah well
him it's because it's not because you're
never supposed to have sex it's because
you're supposed to have sex within the
confinements of this rigidly defined
institution that results in the next
generation of the population it's all
very weird how did this chat become sex
a sex class I honestly don't I think we
I think we got here starting from James
Bond and somehow we ended up here ma'am
would the fiftieth have been better if
it was Derrick Jacoby's war master
versus John Hurt's war doctor
I love it be better it is a shame they
didn't do that I'd like I wish that
existed we have a lot of by rep going on
here awesome you people will hopefully
be happy come Friday I hope so
just label the livestream is educational
that's that's still gonna get me banned
by parent groups hold on let me jump I
gotta jump over to the the discord and
see what I've got over there see did you
see the trailer for Ducks tail season
two I did not
did you see the His Dark Materials
trailer I did looked kind of interesting
but I've never read those books so my
interest is just kind of alright I'll do
one more off here and then I'll come
back to the chat I know a lot of reboots
are terribly but I was a huge fan of
late seventies early eighties sci-fi and
I've got and some have gotten the reboot
treatment like Battlestar Galactica or
Bionic Woman and of course Doctor Who if
you're familiar with this era of sci-fi
television which shows do you think had
an interesting and a premise to be
redone and do you think and what do you
think are the keys to making a
successful return to a show or theme
well I mean like I could do a whole
thing on what I think makes first
successful revisiting reboot to remake
whatever but like with that era
specifically that's not really my bag 7
CDs daddy's TV sci-fi specifically and
most of the stuff that I would think
would be good to try and ring visit has
been revisited maybe not has always
worked but like it would have been stuff
like Battlestar Galactica v I mean I
suppose they could take a crack at Max
Headroom I would want them to have Matt
firor involved somehow
I think I'm Tom I hate quantum leap
makes the most sense as a as a concept
to try giving the update to space 1999
could get a reboot and a retitle
I hung out with a gay guy from middle
school and found out he was racist
during our date super fun oh dang that's
that's one of them that's one of those
things that can really bum you out is to
either reconnect or even just find
somebody on social media like oh I
remember them and then like you look
through their feet a little bit and
you're like oh oh well crap I and I
would imagine like if you're with them
in person and that sinks in it's even
worse
big fan from Cuba thanks for the LGBT
videos I'm bisexual myself they're very
good how awesome thank you
I said bisexual bisexuality
representation video coming on Friday
it's not gonna be as structured as the
ones I do myself because this is one of
the ones where I bring on a guest who
identifies as the specific part of LGBTQ
plus that I'm talking about and we just
have a conversation about the
representation there is what's
problematic what's good and and things
like that and I know I've been promising
this one for a while so I'll be glad to
finally get it out there quantum leap
may be Hercules I remember this episode
with Cupid and I just watch for that oh
I keep forgetting about legends of
Hercules were they doing Xena
reboot whatever happened to that did
that fall apart I can't remember
you'll be happy to let the video out of
the closet let it be free and fabulous
it got scrapped oh okay then what thank
thanks Caroline
yeah I'm not shocked I remember there
being a big sort of why are you why is
everything getting a revival but you're
rebooting Xena
especially when Lucy Lawless and forgive
me I forget the name of the woman who
please get real like still can
definitely play these parts like look at
Lucy Lawless and she's absolutely still
up for this I remember that being a deal
so I guess I I guess I had honestly
forgotten that that was a thing it makes
sense that it fell apart though given
that the reaction I'm feeling attacked I
love the truth shown adventure books as
a kid I remember reading um a couple of
those it's funny the very first one I
ever read which was like a simplified
like grade school one cuz like you got
ones that were like thicker and like
more involved and more gruesome in the
deaths but when I was in grade school
you had ones that were thinner and you
know there were some that would still
kill you but like in very ambiguous ways
you know falling in a pit you know
things like that
not particularly detailed but I do
remember the first one I ever read first
time reading it I got a happy ending
like first try and I remember thinking
oh okay and I think it actually left
lesson of an impression on me because I
didn't hit a bad ending on my first kaho
Lucy Lawless looks amazing and she does
and she's just kind of awesome I guess a
person
are we talking about pick a path books
here I mean I guess that's another way
to put it have you watched sex education
on Netflix I have not
Lucy flawless uh-huh yeah that works
Lucy luck Lucy Lawless was the actress
who played Xena Warrior Princess is what
she's best known for she was also in the
first season of Spartacus on Starz I
heard something about Xena but no I
found out last year no sorry I'm jumping
I'm catching conversations that are
going on in the chat trying to figure
out what's actually directed at me I had
I had Zelda choose your own adventure
books they were a little disappointing
because all you had to do to get a good
ending was not act like an idiot ah yeah
yeah sounds about right
you know what's funny about the
choose-your-own-adventure the company
that makes those is based out of her
menthe
the only reason I know that was um it
got mentioned offhandedly and an article
talking about the fact that they're
trying to sue Netflix over the
Bandersnatch thing Animorph books I was
a little too old for ant nemours when
that came out or at least my reading
level was a little too high like I think
there are some people my age who who got
into it but I feel like it was mostly
people two three years younger than me
who got into those is it weird that I'm
toying with the idea of playing Annabel
in I'm not gonna do the French
pronunciation but the stage version of
The Birdcage
even though I know experience doing drag
um no I don't think so I mean for
something like that where it's in a play
and you're playing a character it's an
acting challenge and like in I I would I
would expect if you were to play that
part that you would do
researching you we do training you would
practice walking in heels and you'd
learn how to keep a wig on your head and
things like that as part of the
preparation for the role I know I don't
actually even think it's that weird well
would be weird is if you were cast and
not required to do any kind of prep that
would be weird I wasn't a big reader
growing up now I love reading I'm
actually kind of the reverse well not
entirely not like to say that like I
don't like reading but like I almost
never have time for Rudy anymore I used
to read a lot but not so much these days
your morning videos like a cup of coffee
ha ha ha ha yeah a Tuesday videos aren't
very much of a thing anymore but like I
I wanted to get the The Lion King thing
out um you know fairly soon after I'd
seen it you know while it would still be
topical um but I had to get the San
Diego comic-con wall on out first cuz
that was gone that was gonna date even
worse and I didn't want to shift other
stuff around or put it way later in the
schedule so I just said heck with it
I'll do a Tuesday video haven't done one
in a while so there you go do you read
audiobooks no I do listen to audiobooks
though sorry I'm being a pedantic
jackass um yeah on occasion um it sort
of depends on on what the book is
because depending on the nature of the
narrative I I'm I may not really be able
to do anything more involved in driving
I know that makes it sound like
distracted driving but like I've been
driving for so long doesn't require a
lot of my active attention unless I'm
dealing with stuff like stoplights are
weird traffic and I'm on the highway for
a lot of my driving for most of the most
of long stretches I have to do but um
like it's hard for me to listen to an
audio book like what say when I'm at
work or while I'm editing because like
my brain is actively engaged in doing
something other than listening is it
weird that the live-action Little
Mermaid has a black Ariel and white
Triton mm no why why would why would
that be weird like multiracial families
are a thing I think we know that right
and not like a weird strange oddity
that's just like a thing that happens
are there any straight characters in
movie or TV that are gender
non-conforming because whenever I see a
feminine guy in a movie they are always
gay is this damaging well it whether or
not it's damaging is hard to say I
you're sort of getting into queer coding
a bit gay male coding specifically and
like I have started working on a script
for an eventual video because gay coding
is absolutely on the docket for me to
deal with eventually um the thing is at
this point that and forgive me but that
persona of just being fabulous and oh
darling is just so ingrained in the
popular culture as being gay that the
audience wouldn't believe you
if you had a character behaving like
that who was not gay and to a certain
degree there is even some validity in
that because that whole fabulousness is
an affectation it's one that people
choose and there's nothing inherently
wrong with it
but that's not a natural accent there
isn't a gay accent there is a choice to
speak in that manner and so the whole
thing is very weird kind of in the first
place um but in general if you were to
go on the more toned-down
end of that um where maybe you just had
a male character dress not excessively
masculine maybe just have nail polish
and leave it at that and have them play
it straight I'd like to see that kind of
thing happen but when you get into more
effeminate
modes of speech and mannerisms
hand gestures and things like that just
the audience won't believe you that
they're not gay because it's just so
ingrained somebody asked what is gay
coding okay quickly as I can
coding in general is they are traits
given to a character things like manners
of speaking ways of behaving body
language things etc that relay certain
things about the character and generally
are shortcuts so that the audience will
make presumptions about that character
so again strictly speaking there's no
biological reason why a gay man acts
like this but it's been coded in
entertainment that that is how gay
characters act so when you have a
character act like that that immediately
leads to an audience as gay because that
is what has been coded through the
stories in the entertainment that we
have coding does not always have to be
intentional oftentimes it's accidental
there's a lot of coding that is like
comes back from generations previously
and it gets recycled and we don't always
know where it comes from
Lindsey Ellis dinner brought that up
when she did her video on bright the
Netflix movie talking about racial
coding with certain fantasy races and
which is usually something that when it
comes up now in modern-day fantasy is
something the creators don't realize
because it's ingrained from the fantasy
tropes established decades ago so coding
is a weird thing to try and dig into how
you doing what's the topic we're talking
about I don't know dude we're all over
the place
tonight like this has been this has been
a roller coaster Disney Villains gay
code yes Disney has a lot of gay code at
villains they by no means have a
monopoly on that there are lots of gay
coded villains all over entertainment
Disney animated films have
a lot though so many trailers drop this
week yeah but a long way didn't care
about like it chapter two I'm sorry I
don't care
see I think coding can help with trying
to get under the radar or with news
shows like Steven universe did at the
beginning with racial coding of amethyst
and garnet yet look the other thing
we're throwing about coding is coding is
not automatically bad coding is just a
thing that happens
it's presence doesn't make things
anything bad or good and honestly it's
one of those things that like it's gotta
happen what do you mean it or not so
saying that something is gay coded or
racially coded or whatever does not
automatically mean that that is a bad
thing but it is a reality of what
happens and it can it can be a good
thing here can't be a bad thing is
completely situational he's an actual
drag queen gonna play her so uh that'd
be fabulous
I like part of you would get a kick out
of that and part of me would be like I
don't know how about chocolate-coated
well my my beverage is chocolate coated
Jody Tennant and Jenna Coleman are doing
a children in need album which makes me
so happy and proud but sadly some people
said it was a publicity stunt enough to
recover from series eleven oh for God's
sake okay I'll go back to what I said
when I did my video on representation
for the quote/unquote wrong reasons even
if it is a publicity stunt is for
charities for a good cause regardless so
shut up like in my mind the only reason
to call that out is if like it Kevin
Spacey tried to do a children need
special let's call that out because that
is in it for a PR boost these people
don't need a PR boost they're fine
so like even if you think it is to mend
you know some kind of image which again
doesn't make any sense because Doctor
Who regard even if you think series 11
was a total failure
that would be an artistic failure
because people will still argue the
ratings thing you're not gonna get into
that but even if you call it a artistic
or even a ratings failure it is not a
public relations failure so doing
something for our PR stunt PR boost
makes no sense
because the problems that these people
are claiming the show has wouldn't be
fixed by a PR boost like so
protect characters from JK Rowling she's
trying to diversify our universe of
mainly straight white people by using
crappy stereotypes and unknown
characters I'm not touching JK Rowling
today I just I'm just not up for it
have you seen the Picard trailer I did I
mentioned it earlier like it looks fine
yeah doctor who has always done
something for children and he yeah and
that's the other thing like it's
actually traditional for the show that's
at this point take a set for the Picard
trailer yeah it was a was the question
already asked so everybody drink pardon
me I'm jumping back to the to the
discord see what else I had gotten over
there um thoughts on Jessica Jones
season three I salving done more than
the first episode I started working my
way through legends of tomorrow first
because I was in the mood for fun I
think stranger things season three you
got to put me in a mood for a wanting
fun and legends of tomorrow is fun
so there you go any thoughts on why some
properties just keep getting remade for
instance Twilight Zone then is in its
fourth iteration fourth attempt at The
Munsters is in the works
lost track of Addams Family reboots etc
yeah because in the world of big-budget
entertainment because even quote-unquote
low-budget TV's and movies you're still
talking millions of dollars recycling a
name or a concept that has worked at a
point in the past that's considered a
form of risk avoidance so the this
this is why we're kind of in an
interesting period because the things
getting rebooted and were remade that's
not new like things were getting read in
I know it feels like we're getting a lot
more of it now but things were getting
remade in the 90s they were getting
remained in the 80s and the 70s and the
60s the forties the The Maltese Falcon
the version with with Humphrey Bogart
that's a remake that's the second
adaptation to that book but the thing is
we're in a weird place right now where
before we just had a reboot cycle where
things would come back around but it's
kind of expanded out firstly because we
had enough successful relaunches of
stuff that would have been considered
sacred like the idea of quote/unquote
remaking Planet of the Apes was kind of
sacrilege religious until they did it
well Tim Burton did it in a sock but and
then they get it again and it was good
so like this a whole sort of sacred
calves you can't remake that it feels
like we don't actually have many of
those left that's the first thing and
the other thing is like we're gonna keep
cycling through these because it's it's
just considered a safer bet and the
reason we get a lot of them we seem to
be getting them at an increasing rate is
because at this point most of the
studios want to release blockbusters
most of the major studios have moved
away from the mid to your budget movie
and if you want a film that is going to
rake in hundreds of millions of dollars
like half a billion minimum worldwide
then you need to launch it
then you need to you're gonna have to
spend a lot of money to be able to do
that and part of mitigating the risk is
to attach a name that people already
know so that's why as we exist currently
in an age of massive blockbusters and a
lot of them why more and more and more
and more these things get brought back
but why I said why we're kind of being
an interesting time is we're also right
now in a time where franchises don't go
dormant in the first place anymore
because you mention something like The
Addams Family which has been you know
rebooted so
times but you look at stuff that is just
flat-out started up more recently like I
like to use the examples of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles it's never gone
away it's been technically rebooted
several times but it's never gone
dormant and we're in a weird and Pokemon
has never gone away and we're in a weird
place where franchise don't act actually
go quiet anymore they just sustained
forever and so we're actually kind of
hitting a point where a lot of the stuff
that has been made from 90s forward
doesn't even really get rebooted because
it never left it's worse I feel like
we're in a strange transitional phase in
a lot of ways it wasn't so much why
remakes why these specifically um I mean
I don't know I mean I I think a lot all
the time isn't a lot of thought that
goes into why they choose what they
choose it depends on who gets attached
to it because sometimes you get somebody
with vision who goes ooh I have a good
idea for that specifically and you know
things like the toilets don't lend
themselves to a lot of very creative
storytelling and I think other times you
get a studio going we're sitting on this
IP who wants it and those give it to
whoever whoever they can so I'm not I'm
not actually sure that enough thought
goes into it that I can break down why
some of these things specifically if
you're asking me to say you know why are
these still appealing like well because
they're good ideas why do they keep
getting rebooted because somebody thinks
it'll help make money Power Rangers has
never stopped one continuous continuity
yeah no that's true with that that was
another thing I was slightly too old for
their systematically releasing Hogwarts
house themed Harry Potter books to
coincide with the 20th anniversary
release of each book would you want a
Slytherin Harry Potter themed set if
probably not because like I already own
every book and I own every book in
hardcover and I'm not enough of a
collector to be like oh now I need
this edition of the exact same thing I
already have I'm not that person as much
as I enjoy Slytherin merge
I don't need literally the exact books
that I already own only in hardcover
again just with Slytherin stuff on
besides that would actually feel really
weird knowing how badly Slytherin has a
house is treated and the books it would
feel odd in a way
choosing the Hufflepuff peope Hufflepuff
paperbacks
I can speak to old for power ranges I
assumed you were about one II you liar
you did not assume that flattered but no
you didn't uh Natalie Portman's Thor Wow
well I mean having actually read at
least some of the of the Thor god of
thunder stuff it's it's actually pretty
good
um let me get back to the discord give
me a second how where was I
all right so I've got kind of a long ish
one here so bear with me folks I got to
try and get through some of these all
right so this is someone who is
elaborating on something that I actually
got said last week about the fact that
said truth Rock died in the 90s I still
feel we have real rock bands nowadays
but most if not all are either doing
song are either doing songs about our
not very famous or our rock bands that
do this new rap rock that has been
popular is rap rock still popular I feel
like that was on its way out
my last favorite band was no doubt I not
not a fan personally I they were being
they going to say you know who no doubt
was I know who no doubt was I'm not hmm
sure there are those pop rock bands too
but i feel those true rock bands where
guitars would be played with solos and
guitar players are known for their
type of thing has for the most part died
out I think part of this is because the
popularity of rap R&B and pop which is
the new center for most popular radio
stations okay so it's what it sounds
like you're going with and I'll kind of
agree with is that rock as the
predominant form of popular music has
died yes there are still rock bands out
there but you're you're kind of right
don't get the primary radio play it's a
bit more of a niche thing at this point
you know the more traditional you know
master guitarists style rock but it's
still around definitely pop on back here
it's just me or does every gauge
character and everything you have to
have a big reveal it does seem that
happens a lot
Iron Maiden is the best rock band
changed my mind
I thought they were considered heavy
metal which I mean I suppose is a form
of rock I'm just saying do you listen to
Time Lord rock I I don't know if that's
actually a thing if it is I guess no
there's a good YouTube video on the
death of rock by David Bennett piano
there's also a good song by miracle of
sound called the death of rock and roll
so go ahead and check that out it's a
rock song hint Rock of the doll favorite
rock band is panic at the disco would
they be considered rock I mean I think
that's part of the other thing I feel
like we've subdivided musical genres so
much and like every is in a very
specific need I don't actually know what
what's considered rock out of current
bands like hate to say it but like I
know Nickelback would be considered pop
rock but a form of rock and that's not
me endorsing the band I'm just saying
like I can identify that
Time Lord rock is a thing though I think
they call it rock some of it's pretty
good
I'm fond of an awful lot of running in
last type 40 ok I'm curious are you
excited for the new Star Wars TV show
the Mandalorian I keep forgetting it's a
thing that's gonna happen so I guess not
like maybe we want to get a proper
trailer I'll start to be but like right
now I guess it's a concept I very rarely
get super excited for concepts because I
know so much is always gonna be
dependent on execution so until I start
getting a taste of execution which
unless I'm super familiar with the
director and have a ton of faith in them
like I would with someone like say Gamal
del Toro or or Christopher Nolan you
know someone who I know that I can trust
their work then it usually isn't until a
trailer that I'm gonna get anything
close to excited because it's always
executed independent and I don't get
pumped from concepts anymore panic was
originally alternative rock but it
slowly turned more Popish have you
watched years and years nope I don't
have HBO anymore which is how it aired
in the US Plus um I've heard it's very
good but very depressing not really
looking to be depressed these days
see in the Lion King pitch meeting by
Ryan George I actually haven't seen that
one I have certain watching Ryan Georgia
stuff but Ivan like been binging through
it like one or two a day I'll do his
stuff if you haven't checked out his
stuff it's it's very funny it's very
punchy it's very clever so when some of
us gets run into like the three minute
plus I think sometimes they get iffy but
especially anything that's on the
shorter side of him it's quite clever
and he does very very rapid fire comedy
in the way he cuts together the his
little sketches in his videos so you
know I'd like his stuff but I haven't
seen that one specifically why do people
still insist on screwing fruit food
service workers ah um lingering sense of
superiority because the thing is for a
very long time jobs like restaurant
worker or you know basic retail jobs
they they were the jobs the people who
couldn't afford or couldn't get into
college had and so anyone who had a
called Bri will look down and they were
thought of as the jobs of the uneducated
and I think in a lot of ways they still
are and there might even be a certain
degree to that but there there has
traditionally been a sense of elitism
and superiority associated with that
it's a service job you are you are here
to service me that makes me superior to
you because you serve me part of its in
just in the nature of the job that
screwed up it's not right but like again
I think there's a lot of a lot of
baggage built in with that kind of
occupation well thank you Meg
I mean quite generous this time around
at least we got some rock bands still
touring I saw Queen two weeks ago with
Adam Lambert mm I'm not a huge fan of
him either um that show slapped like I
cried three times and lost my voice well
that's good I'm glad you enjoyed it I'm
glad you had you
a good time with that we should prefer
how would sure John Powell or hand
Zimmer - for your personal life score a
John Powell please retail workers are
probably more so than most white-collar
jobs ironically well yeah see the thing
is the the lowest paid and most under
regarded jobs they are foundational and
entire businesses and indeed entire
societies are built on top of them and
you need this to build anything else
above that but this is treated like crap
because there's more of them
so there's they're considered disposable
not important there's only there's only
one CEO at the head of the company they
must be super special
blasphemy we only talk about Queen when
Freddie is the lead oh boy that's that's
kinda that's gonna spark a war I feel
you should not be treating food service
workers badly because they control the
food coming your table um I mean that's
the logical thing aside from just that
you know be a nice person they handle
your food that seems like a bad idea to
take them off can we tell about I get
quite heated over retail workers who get
treated like crap as well you should um
cuz nobody deserves to be treated like
garbage I mean like say nobody
some people have actually actively
earned it but people simply doing a job
that is especially if it's one where
they're working for somebody else like
they probably didn't choose this job
it's just how they're paying their bills
it's and you know like people get
crapped on for just being the person who
picked up the phone sometimes do you
watch American Horror Story I'm like
three seasons with three or four seasons
behind at this point so not currently
share still does an amazing show I don't
doubt it like she's one of those
consummate performers I think I'm gonna
wrap it up soon I'm gonna pop on back to
the discord real quick got an off topic
query if there is a topic no there isn't
huh how I was wondering how frequently
you enjoy playing around with headcanon
characters as gender and sexual
minorities that might not be canon um it
what I do it it's not something I do
consciously it's not something that I
like think down think down
who sit down and think ooh what people
might be something other than straight
that I could you know imagine him and
maybe justify it's not something I do
actively but it is something I do to a
certain degree but I think like it just
kind of happens on its own so I mean I
guess I could say I enjoy it cuz I kind
of do it but like again it's not like a
project it's just something that happens
oh geez which brother see Tarantino
making Kill Bill Vol three or directing
Star Trek movie is his last project I
this whole Tarantino directed Star Trek
thing is so weird to me I I don't I
don't even know what to make of it and
the notion of a Kill Bill Vol degree
depends on the concept depends on the
story um so last one I'm gonna do off
the discord what are your thoughts on
the Mulan trailer um I liked it I
thought it looks I thought it looked
good the reaction has been stupid but I
thought it actually looked quite good
yeah I think I am gonna I am gonna wrap
it up folks so no live stream next week
I will be on vacation
but I hope everyone has a good rest of
the month
I guess cuz I won't I won't see you
again until August I'll live anyways
videos are still supposed to go up on
their normal days well I'm on vacation
they'll be they'll be pre scheduled but
um yeah that'll be it for for me for
this time
uh-huh this was fun to do life finally
rushed home for it I'm glad you made it
don't be arrested listen it's a family
vacation all right I'm not planning to
have crazy wild nights on this one all
right but hope everyone has a good rest
of the month they tuning in your support
your comments everything you do so just
remember folks your beautiful your valid
you are loved you are the counsel
I'm just running meetings see ya